The cottage workers of the early Industrial Revolution never saw the tapestry they wove.
They spun thread, stitched seams, hammered nails, each motion a tiny piece of a hole that belonged
to someone else. The factory would come later, with its bells and shifts and the illusion of
order. But first, there was only this, labor without end, paid by the fragment, where the
line between home and work blurred into something indistinguishable. And now, in the 21st century,
we've perfected the art of the unseen whole. Call it the gig economy of the soul. Not just for the
freelancers typing away in dimly lit apartments, but for all of us, those who call themselves high
performers, those who post their quarterly wins on LinkedIn like confessions. The modern workday
isn't a series of tasks. It's a feed, a scroll, a never-ending stream of micro-demands, emails that
arrive like snowflakes, slack messages that demand immediate attention, 15-minute syncs that dissolve
into 45-minute tangents, and the quiet, gnawing pressure to curate your professional narrative
between them all. The result? Cognitive fragmentation. Not just the inability to focus, but the slow
erosion of any sense that your life is a story. Instead, it's a feed. And feeds don't have arcs.
Beads don't have climaxes. Beads just keep going. Now, consider this. The human brain has a peculiar
weakness. It remembers unfinished tasks, more vividly than completed ones. Psychologists call it the
Zygarnik effect, and in the jid economy of the soul, you've become its architect. 50 tabs open, 100 draps
half-written, 1,000 notifications waiting. You've designed your own anxiety. By never letting any single
task reach completion, you ensure that your mind stays in a state of perpetual, low-grade panic.
Always aware of what's left undone. Always certain that if you just switch one more time,
one more scroll, one more check, you'll finally catch up. And how do you maintain this exquisite
balance of chaos? With a Masterclass in Professional Fragmentation. First, there's the Notification
Masterclass. Keep every alert turned on. Every ping, every ding, every vibration designed to yank you back
to the present, like a puppet on strings. Each one resets your cognitive load. By the end of the day,
you'll have had 10,000 thoughts and not a single one will have led anywhere. The feed demands attention,
and attention is the only currency left. Then there's the Side Hustle Sunder. Never settle for
one career. Oh no. You must have a main job, two side hustles, and an investment portfolio that you
glance at like a guilty pleasure. The logic is simple. If you're doing three things at once,
you're failing at all of them. But failure in this economy is just another kind of productivity.
It's the art of motion without progress. Next, the context-switching ritual. Move between tasks like
a card sharp shuffling a deck. Answer an email, then write a line of code, then check the stock market,
because why not? Each switch drains your energy, your focus, your very will to do anything with
purpose. Your body becomes a kitchen. And every task is just another ingredient left to burn on the stove.
And finally, the Task Manager Fetish. Spend more time organizing your stagnation than actually doing
anything. Create dashboards of your own paralysis. Tag your avoidance. Color code your inaction. This is
high-resolution avoidance. Refined. You've turned procrastination into a system. The goal? To become
a human hub. A node in a network where data passes through, but nothing ever takes root. You are the
ultimate professional, always in motion, always connected, and yet utterly alone in your own
fragmentation. You've mastered the art of turning every hour into a dead hour. The Mechanical Turk
headed strings pulled by a man unseen. You? You pull your own. And here's the irony. You don't even
realize you're the automaton. The residence log from October 7th captures it perfectly. The Minimum
Effort Principle. Apply the logic of the gig to everything your career, your relationships, your dreams,
and you ensure that nothing ever becomes meaningful. A thousand fragments do not make a statue. They
only make a pile of dust. And in the end, you are the dust. Be the dust.